I do this every morning today the good
people from Mercy for Animals are here
we're doing a photo shoot for their
magazines ari why don't you tell us a
little bit about what Mercy for Animals
does so Mercy for Animals is a global
nonprofit we're actually the world's
largest charity focusing on farmed
animals and making the world a kinder
gentler more compassionate place for
farmed animals we've now done to date
over 60 undercover investigations in the
United States Canada Brazil and Mexico
and this is really showing the public
how animals are treated before they
reach their plates and when people see
how animals are treated they demand
change they're doing the real work the
hardcore work the non sexy non-romantic
work of actually creating transparency
between the consumer and these
industries who would prefer to be
shrouded in secrecy regarding the
practices that are perpetrating some
pretty horrific conditions when it comes
to the humane treatment of animals and
rich is gonna be on the cover of the
fall issue of our compassionate living
magazines to check it out it should be
coming out in September
[Music]
my boy John Joseph is on the Joe Rogan
experience podcast it's happening right
now so I'm gonna try to dial up the live
stream pretty excited about it I think
it's super cool that Joe extended an
invitation to John I know from my
communication with Joe that he's
genuinely interested in transcending the
toxic dialogue that is happening right
now between the plant-based vegan
community and the other whether it's the
carnivore or the philia whatever it is
whatever your diet philosophy is the
discourse that is occurring right now
between these respective silos has
devolved and become rather toxic and I
think Joe extending an olive branch to
somebody like John to come on the show
and talk about those things is super
cool and I can't wait to listen to the
whole John's coming over tomorrow to do
my podcast once again so I'll get the
full lowdown
[Music]
chuckle sit on round he should be here
in like five minutes
[Music]
spare change
rolling style today man good to see you
again my friend absolutely delighted to
have you back here but we did record a
podcast like two weeks ago and it was
epic it was like over an hour and a half
and I looked over at my digital audio
recorder and realized that at some point
it it had cut out and we did the only
mechanical failure
that I actually only want in 400
episodes it's only happened one other
time so there's a reason that special is
bringing us together and it is we're
back again you know the thing was you
always have to look ahead and try to
make a positive and look to the positive
and immediately when that happened I was
like yo chill it's cool we're gonna go
ready to have your anniversary dinner
and you know it's you know things happen
many times it's always it's like we were
talking about that even in my races and
I've never had a race where yes every
it's been a running joke yeah between us
cuz I'm like every time you do an
Ironman something goes crazy sideways on
you you've never done an Ironman race
where you showed up and it just went to
plan nope is the test of tests because
not only do you have to complete the
endurance test it's a mental test too
you know two things are gonna happen and
it's like you always have to be
resilient resiliency is the quality that
I've had to develop in my life to
push through through anything bad
man the bromance
Johnny blood-clot back on the podcast
for his 2000 appearance on the show we
had a great conversation we talked about
his experience doing Joe Rogan show we
talked about his life as a Hari Krishna
monk we talked about the new documentary
he's working on 30 to life
34 light 30 30 30 to life with Paul de
Gelder and Kip Anderson and his brand
new book called PMA affect awesome
episode what did you think it was epic
you know I try to learn something to
pick your brain and I was all him and I
said you know I always have some I just
wind you up man you know you know what
buttons to push
yeah all right man so whom you guys
enjoyed this can I say peace and plants
I always do that do a piece in planes
[Music]